♪ [співають вірменською] ♪
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Київ,
Наддніпрянщина]
Це був гуртожиток консерваторії,
він був залитий водою, зруйнований.
[Борис Єгіазарян
Художник]
Ми, художники, взяли, полагодили дах
й все інше та зробили собі майстерню.
П'ятий поверх, без ліфта.
Ми думали придбати ліфт.
Але туди полотна не влізають.
Бачите ці клаптики помаранчевого кольору?
Під час Помаранчевої революції  тут діяла
організація художників «Помаранчевий квадрат».
З усієї України художники приїхали,
в майстерні був наш штаб.
♪ [співають вірменською] ♪
Мені подобається це розповідати
в присутності моєї дружини.
Це мій такий жарт, що я в Криму зустрів українку,
вона мене обдурила й одружила із собою.
Мені тоді було 19 років.
З 1988 року до 1993 року я був у Вірменії,
тому що там почалася революція.
Антирадянський рух, а потім почалась
війна із сусідньою країною — Азербайджаном.
І до 1993 року я не міг звідти поїхати.
Бо там на початку були створені
добровольчі загони, аби захищати кордони.
І я пішов добровольцем із загоном мого села.
Я не міг у ті тяжкі часи залишити
Вірменію і приїхати до Києва.
Навпаки, моя дружина приїздила до мене
на місяць-два, аби мене зігріти.
А ось уже в 1993 році у Вірменії
ці труднощі минули.
І я перевівся до Київської художньої академії
(тоді Українська академія мистецтва).
[сміється] Єгіазарян! Перериваюся.
Даю інтерв'ю про тебе, тільки хороше розповідаю.
[Роман Балаян
Кінорежисер]
Він каже передати дівчатам,
щоб не боялися Балаяна — він хороший.
Навіть кращий, ніж Єгіазарян. Чуєш, так?
Ну все, все, давай.
Це Борис мене вважає таким (генієм),
а я вважаю, що я є одним із...
може це прозвучить нещиро:
я  — один із тисячі.
Хіба ми знаємо всіх світових
режисерів, які є в різних країнах?
Хороших.
Можливо, не тисяча. Нехай буде триста,
чотириста, п'ятсот.
А мені цього не вистачає.
Я не зняв жодного фільма
про радянську владу.
Мені пропонували про шахтарів,
про сталеварів, про колгоспників.
Мене ніхто не міг змусити
робити те, чого я не хочу.
Ось одна картина зі серії «Дім-місто».
Ось так.
А це жінки, котрі збирають шовковицю.
У Вірменії  зазвичай тримають біле простирадло
і трясуть дерево, а шовковиця падає.
Були часи, у тих же 1990-х роках, коли нас друзі
до Америки запрошували жити.
Казали: «Все допоможемо, все зробимо,
ти тут станеш дуже дорогим художником».
Але я сказав: «Ні».
Якщо я у Вірменію не повертаюся,
(були причини, чому не повертаюся),
то я залишаюся в Україні, нікуди не поїду.
Подобається мені тут, в Україні.
Любо мені тут.
Якщо б ще тут не було сепаратизму
і зради своєї країни, тут узагалі би добре було.
Але нічого, потихеньку і це мине.
Ще одне покоління і  цей Радянський Союз
змиється, й тут буде гарна країна.
І буде по-європейськи і за власними
традиціями українськими.
А я радий, що я своє вірменське
приніс сюди, й отримую тут українське.
— [вірменською] Борисе, вітання!
— [вірменською] Вітання!
Це Крістіна та Лаура, ми йдемо просто на репетицію
і вирішили вам зателефонувати.
Я вас так і не спитала про картину,
яку ви написали.
Як вона називається?
Там згори напис вірменською:
— [вірменською] Благословення.
— Так.
— [вірменською] Подяка.
— [вірменською] Радість.
— Овва!
[з телефону] Що в перекладі означає
«Благословення, подяка, радість».
Неймовірно.
— Тож я вам у дім подарував благословення, подяку.
— Дякуємо Вам.
Щоб ви завжди дякували Богу,
благословляли і раділи життю.
Дуже дякуємо Вам.
♪ [співають вірменською] ♪
Від кого я почула вірменські пісні — це наша бабуся.
[Лаура Мартіросян
Співачка, музикантка]
Вона так співала, просто неймовірно,
це просто треба було чути.
Із цієї пісні все починалось, так називається перший
альбом — «Крунк» [з вірменської — журавель].
І, напевно, все життя і нашим дітям
ми теж будемо співати «Крунк».
— Ще мама сказала, що два голоси...
— Мама взагалі мріяла, щоб ми разом співали.
Але ми роз'їхались, і я вже співала бразильську
музику, потім Крістіна приєдналась до мене.
І вона сказала: «Слухай мені так би хотілося
зробити щось наше, народне».
А я якраз чекала щось таке.
І кажу: «Слухай, давай».
Нам вдалося зробити цей мікс
європейського джазу з вірменським мелосом.
Ми вірмени, які жили на території Азербайджану.
Як кажуть, що вірмен зараз більше по світові,
бо до цього був перший геноцид.
І всі, як гранат, вірмени розсипались.
І кажуть, що зараз у самій Вірменії
вірмен живе менше, ніж за її лаштунками.
І потім уже була друга хвиля [міграції],
через багато-багато років.
Мені було шість з половиною років,
Лаурі було два з половиною роки.
[Крістіна Мартіросян
Співачка, музикантка]
Наші батьки навчалися в Харкові,
тому вони були там, а ми були у дідуся з бабусею.
Мама якимось чином змогла
знайти людину в поліції.
Вона була в Харкові, на відстані.
Нас таємно, уночі, вивозили у меблях.
В килимах.
І ми знову переїхали, вже в Україну.
Україна стала нашим домом, місцем,
що врятувало наші життя, слава Богу.
Ми співали багато тому,
що бабуся нам співала.
Та й усі загалом співали постійно,
коли приходили гості.
Мені здається, що ми почали
займатися джазом не просто так.
З початку нашої музикальної освіти джаз був.
Але ми його не розуміли,
ми його ще не досягнули.
Джаз — це як і спілкування іншими мовами.
Ми розвиваємося все далі й далі,
щоразу більше і більше, яскравіше.
Як і життя людини, як і мови, так і музика.
♪ [лунають молитовні співи] ♪
Взагалі у Вірменії є ось таких
два, напевно, великих культа.
Це культ родини,
і культ старшого покоління, батьків.
Тому на будь-які великі церковні свята,
ми збираємось разом, всією родиною.
[Србуі Амбарцумян
Лікарка]
Що більше людей прийде, то краще.
Має бути дуже пишний стіл.
Це символізує благополуччя,
те, що ми приносимо Господу Христу.
Основна страва, яку готує будь-яка
вірменська родина, — рис із сухофруктами.
Рис символізує в цьому святі народ:
чистий, білий, нічим не заплямований.
Усі сухофрукти — це як люди-праведники,
які несуть віру в цей народ.
Вони дають цьому рису бути трішки солодшим.
Друга страва, яка обов'язково має бути, — це риба.
У вірмен є така традиція: відварену червону рибу
прикрашати обов'язково гранатом.
Поєднання червоної риби, граната
і тархуну дуже смачне.
Класично ми готуємо «Олів'є», готуємо «Шубу»,
нарізки, те ж сало можемо готувати.
Українські страви також ми беремо.
♪ [співають вірменською] ♪
Я думаю, що зберігати традиції неважко,
тому що це у нас з дитинства.
Ми виросли вже в родині, у нас
було багато родичів, тих хто поряд.
Можливо, був якийсь переломний момент у школі,
коли ти виділяєшся серед інших.
Десь, можливо, в інституті,
але вже в такому більш зрілому віці — ні.
Давайте вип'ємо за Батьківщину.
Кожному дорога своя Батьківщина,
там, де ти народився, і там, де ти живеш.
Обидві Батьківщини нам дорогі. За Батьківщину!
За українсько-вірменську дружбу.
[звук цокання келихів]
Що дуже цінно для нас.
Я зараз їду по Україні і бачу, пейзаж український.
Я бачу цей ліс, цей захід сонця,
світанок і я бачу, як це треба писати.
Тридцять років я не міг зрозуміти пейзаж,
воно все якесь зелене.
Густо-зелене, смачно-зелене, а де колір?
А у Вірменії сонце таке, що те саме зелене дерево,
воно жовте, помаранчеве, десь червоне.
Ультрамаринове навіть.
А тут я вже почав розуміти ось цю ніжність,
гармонійність, іншу природу, іншу красу.
Тонка краса.
Я часто це кажу, що жінка Параджанова казала,
що його буйним вірменським живописом
пройшлась українська музикальність,
ніжність, поетичність.
Ось це відбулося з моїм живописом.
Свого часу я послав Параджанова.
Вісім місяців з ним не розмовляв.
Хоча й шкодував, не припиняв думати,
що він геній і таке інше.
За вісім місяців,
1973 року,
кіностудією [Довженка] йде Віктор Джорбенадзе,
художник фільму «Колір граната»
і  «цей» Параджанов, то я так раніше
про нього говорив.
Віктор обіймає мене і каже:
«Помирися з ним, він так переживає».
«Та пішов він!» — кажу,
ну як кавказець такий типовий.
«Я тебе прошу. Ну шо таке?»
«Йди сюди!», тобто підзиває він
Параджанова до мене, пацана,
який тоді лиш «Ефект Ромашкіна» зняв.
Він мене обіймає, Сергій Параджанов, і каже:
«Я б з тобою не помирився,
якби не знав, що через рік помру».
Через вісім місяців його посадили.
Геній, він мав те передчуття.
Я не хотів з ним знайомитися.
До «Тіней [забутих предків]».
Я знав його попередні фільми.
Щось є таке в тих фільмах,
що повторюється у  «Тінях».
Але коли я подивився «Тіні [забутих предків]»...
Дивився з п'ятдесятьма міліціонерами.
Я був вражений.
Я спершу прочитав повість.
Забігаючи наперед, я два роки дзвонив усім
українцям, які дуже страждали за свою мову,
і казав, аби вони прочитали перші п'ять сторінок
«Тіней забутих предків» Коцюбинського.
Це неймовірно.
«А що таке?» — питали.
Ще немає ані Івана, ані Марічки,
мамо рідна, земля дихає, повітря дихає!
Птахи...
Тварини бігають, і все це от так живе!
Потім з'являються Іван, Марічка —
Ромео та Джульєта.
Але перші п'ять сторінок! Я тоді не зрозумів...
А в фільмі це є.
Цей Параджанов... Не «цей», а Параджанов.
Параджанов ніколи... В фільмі немає жодної одежі,
не знятої з місцевих гуцулів.
Він терпіти не міг того, щоб костюми шили
[на замовлення].
Жодного предмета немає.
Всю фонограму «Тіней забутих предків»
щодня крутила [Тетяна] Дерев'янко у звукоцеху.
Вона весь час звучала, ця фонограма.
Сама собою геніальна.
[наспівує]
Там ось так [показує на горло] співають,
а не як в хорі Верьовки.
[наспівує]
Бо він брав натуральних, старих.
[наспівує з різними мотивами]
Це ж зовсім інше.
Я вивчив українську мову, знімаючи
дипломну роботу, 1969 року, серед гуцулів.
Вони завжди говорять українською.
І вони не звертали увагу на те,
що у тебе є суржик.
А тут зважають на це.
Я навіть Борису [Єгіазаряну] казав,
щоб він припинив суржиком говорити.
А гуцулам байдуже.
Україна мені багато дала.
І те, що я пережив з українцями,
Помаранчева революція, Майдан, як душа в душу.
Це збагатило мене.
Єдине, через що я страждаю, —
це те, що я ще суржиком:
то російською,
то українською розмовляю.
Ніяк не можу ось так вільно
розмовляти українською.
♪ [співають] ♪
Ми відчуваємо себе 100 % українками і вірменками.
Те, що з корінням, воно не може не бути у нас.
Якщо пам'ять є у відчуттях, в спогадах,
то хочеться це не просто зробити, а пропрацювати.
Чому я гадаю, що зараз
відчуваю єдність українців і вірмен?
Коли був тут на Майдані, момент такий дуже гарячий, і вся країна була у цьому,
в нас було як тригер,
це був як жахливий спогад,
знову переживати у реальному житті те,
що було зі мною у дитинстві.
Настільки це було тяжко і боляче,
що ми навіть не могли співати.
Ця тема постійно буде.
Ми живемо у цьому кисні,
тому не можемо, дихаючи цим киснем,
не співати і про українське, і про вірменське.
Це в нас.
Вірменська громада в Україні
вважається однією з найбільших.
Така концентрована, сильна громада.
Коли треба, допомагаємо.
Громада дуже зосереджена
навколо вірменської церкви.
Вірмени дуже при церкві.
♪ [лунає молитва вірменською] ♪
Весь вірменський народ сповідує християнство.
В Україні перші християнські приходи,
а також єпископати з'явилися в XI-XII столітті.
[Маркос Оганесян
Глава Української єпархії Вірменської
Апостольської Церкви]
Тобто одразу ж після прийняття християнства
в Київській Русі.
♪ [лунає молитва вірменською] ♪
У нас 14 чинних церков.
Деякі з них  — з XIV століття.
Ми пройшли довгий історичний шлях в Україні.
Цей шлях дає нам можливість
почуватися в оточенні своїх.
♪ [лунає молитва вірменською] ♪
Про Україну я хочу сказати дуже теплі слова,
бо вона для нас рідна.
Слава Богу, що є взаєморозуміння,
оскільки ми — одне ціле.
Ми є частинами церкви Христа.
Конфесії різні, а церква одна.
Як художник  — я тут інакший,
і для вірмен також інакший.
В Україні може здаватися, що я —
типовий вірменський живописець.
Це не так. Для Вірменії я також
відрізняюся як художник.
Буває, що я можу робити за рік
одну, дві, три виставки, чотири виставки.
В Україні мені гарно працюється.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Юлія Рублевська]
[Оператори
Олександр Портян, Михайло Шелест, Олег Сологуб]
[Операторки
Анна Воробйова
Марія Теребус]
[Інтерв'юери
Валерія Діденко, Олександра Панченко,
Олександр Хоменко]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[USAID
Серія відео створена за підтримки Агенства США
з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]